I can't even begin to explain it to you
I'm 33 this year and honestly I thought
oh look at that I guess too young
probably a filter and at least if I
hadn't met someone I would have been
close to meeting someone and honestly it
is so so bad out there so this is
translation I date out of my league
she's like a maybe five six you know 5
she's 335 dating eight I last year got
ghosted on ongoing by so many different
men yeah they probably heard your age
sorry ladies what up guys welcome to the
D pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way in and get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today if you want
to be the ultimate alpha male get
yourself a women sh and vote t-shirt the
women will be coming up to you left
right and Center anyways um today I'm
going to be reacting to women regret
being strong and independent when women
hit the wall we love a good women hit
the wall series just wall in wall wall
anyways let's go reality is often
disappointing even make it up can't even
make it up that is it was can't even
make it up
now reality can be whatever I want I've
been single for a year and deleted and
redownloaded the apps at least a million
times I finally said yes to a date and
I'm going to tell you why I said yes to
that date loved that this man was like
okay that's your favorite restaurant
great I'm going to make reservations for
us at this time on this night like yes
please why is it so hard to find
somebody to do that everyone else is
like hey what's up what's your schedule
maybe we can go for a walk or like I
don't know what do you want to do like
show me that you want to do something
like take charge be a man I know I'm
going to get hate for saying that call
me old fashion
but let's talk about it I am no longer
scared to say it I don't want to be by
myself anymore I am a strong independent
woman I've done everything by myself for
the last few years I know I can do it
and I don't want to anymore I want to
share it with somebody life is meant to
be shared the apps have failed me so uh
if you need me I will be here posting
until I find my soulmate it's like
soulmate even that sounds like a fairy
tale think the last reaction I did was
with Sandman and he was talking about
how women speak in like magical thinking
weird you grow up hearing all these
terms you don't even realize that a lot
of these kind of just sound like
nonsense Series where I share things my
guy friends have said or done that have
completely alter my brain chemistry you
just went on a first date with a guy and
you really like him like you think he's
the one you delete the dating apps you
stop talking to all those other guys
that you were flirting with you start
pinteresting wedding inspo what the hell
are you doing stop do you think he is
doing the same okay we don't actually
know what he's doing but that doesn't
matter it's irrelevant you don't know
this guy and technically you are still
single just because you like him does
not mean he is your boyfriend I've
consistently seen my girlfriends do this
and I don't see my guy friends doing the
same they meet someone that they really
like and they get tunnel vision until he
is your boyfriend you are not so this is
basically a translation for she said her
friends do it so friends go for men out
of their league and those guys kind of
treat them like an option and I mean
yeah that I mean that typically happens
when and usually friend groups are kind
of within the same attractiveness minus
like maybe one two points at most so
this chick's like five six so let's say
her friend's seven sleeping with a nine
yeah that that's kind of what what it's
going to get you girlfriend so do not
act like one because what you will do is
stay hyper fixated on a man and this is
wrong so they say don't act like his
girl well how it's like how would you
ever expect to if you applied for a job
um and you interned for a summer you
would want to demonstrate that you have
the skills for the job but women don't
want to demonstrate that we have wife
skills we have girlfriend skills and
then we expect to get the girlfriend or
wife title and I saw um a psychologist
break down how bad girlgaming is is and
it was so interesting he was like if you
go on a date and a guy says I don't want
to go on a date with you unless I'm
going to get sex you would think that
was crazy but women go on first dates
and say well I don't want to go on a
date unless I'm going to get a
relationship and just how like crazy
that sounds to a guy let me let me see
what else she says that will just end up
breaking your heart so keep those
options open until he is 100% sure sorry
yeah this is how women say be hores just
be a until he's sure about you and
then be surprised when he's not time we
spoke about about how atrocious the
dating scene is throughout what seems to
be Melbourne but I'm sure it is other
areas as well I had a friend send me a
Tik Tok from a fellow melbour girl
talking about this and honestly the
amount that this resonated with me and
my other girlfriends who are also single
going through this I can't even begin to
exp 28 29 my guess 29 poop earrings
equals sleeve tattoos equals
it was heavy makeup s so so spot on it
is honestly sure like I can't even begin
to explain it to you I'm 33 this year
and honestly I thought by this age I
would have met oh look at that I guess
too young probably a filter and at least
if I hadn't met someone I would have
been close to meeting someone and
honestly it is so so bad out there so
this is translation a date out of my
league she's like a maybe at five six
you know five she's 33 five dating eight
um I last year got ghosted ongoing by so
many different men yeah they probably
heard your age sorry ladies um not
saying that I think if you're 30 if I
was 33 you should date 50y olds yes 45
to 50 cuz then you're young to them you
know
anyways sorry meing on the go but
obviously when you do want to meet
someone you want to try and put yourself
out there so I thought I would jump on
here and do a follow up video or another
video relating to my last one because it
seemed to get a lot of comments people
had a lot to say about this situation
there was a lot of women agreeing with
me saying it's not only melin which I'm
so glad it's everywhere yeah yeah we're
we're delusional everywhere um it's
really like sad and disheartening to
hear that other women are going through
this and yeah I don't yeah I just want
to give you guys a a to show you what
the market is half of my generation will
be single and childless the other half
will get married married or have kids
and even out of the ones that get
married half will be divorced so like
hearing those things but it is I guess
com comforting in a way but see she's
admitting misery loves company yes yes
thank God I'm not alone women love to
keep other women miserable people can
kind of relate to what you're going
through um I had a lot of comments
claiming that because of my tattoos or
potential body count
that yeah yeah that would probably lower
my value to a man see it's like it's
like the guys will say look at this is
what we care about and then she it's
like they do the air quotes well what
men care about yeah it is don't shoot
the messenger and to be honest if any or
person thinks that my value imagine a
man says this a man says well um money
doesn't matter and if any woman cares
about my money and my job then I don't
want her or imagine you could do the
same thing do the the same thing
Charisma is lesser than because I have
tattoos I could potentially have a high
body count that's not a person that I
want to be associated with anyway and
it's not a guy that I would be dating so
die alone yeah women can either care
about what men want and adapt um or they
can die alone so I would rather for the
rest of my life than end up with a
person like that there are so many
beautiful women
everywhere and I have I don't remember
the last time I've SE SE an attractive
guy it's been months if he blocked you
that means you have so much power over
him like I want you to think about it
for a second to go through the action of
going on someone's profile okay a women
will often put the way what it means if
a woman does something onto a guy so
she's saying if he blocks you then you
have so much power over him men are much
more simple he probably blocked you
because he doesn't want to deal with you
and you're annoying where when women
block a guy it it's generally more to
get attention so she's pushing the way
that women are onto men to select the
option to block them like that takes a
lot of energy and like thought process
no it doesn't does not it's like two
buttons like you know what this person
bothers me so much that I need to block
see the guys this is how a woman thinks
like a woman will go through the thought
process of block don't block guys are
just like well that's annoying block
they're pretty they're more simple I
need to put boundaries in place because
they affect me avoid women that talk
about bound boundaries yes guys please
it means they've been in some feminist
therapy that makes them crazy the women
that talk about boundaries it's like
okay I'm going to have a bunch of rules
for you to jump through in order to be
in a relationship with me does that
sound appealing to a man much that I
need to block them okay I'm going to
give you a little bit of a mindset
switch here okay in the past I have
blocked certain guys because after the
breakup it was so painful and my friends
were always like just block the guy like
do your thing and I never really had my
own opinion so I just did it because I
was like oh yeah like that just seems
like the thing to do right so after I
blocked do you have a nose job that
looks like a botched nose job um you
kind of like instantly go into this
feeling of like oh my God like they're
gone forever like like that's that's it
like the story is literally done like I
block them like there's nothing else you
can do like that's literally it like
I've cut them out of my life forever so
I've been on the apps a lot this week
because I'm trying to set up dates
because dating someone is a priority to
me even though it's exhausting and I'm
really happy by myself I know that I
need to like do it so I'm like actively
swiping trying to like set up a few days
for next week right and I just got this
match or like this message from a guy in
hinge and he said Amanda it's been 6
months that I've seen you on the apps
and like you seem perfect what's
happening why can't you find someone and
I was like damn that is that I was not
prepared for that ice cold cup of
reality today but fair like the thing is
I know I am still single it's because
daving is exhausting so I'll like I'll
go on like one or two dates they'll be
bad and I'm like oh my God I'm so tired
and then you know what ends up happening
I end up prioritizing my friends and and
my alone time like I'm so happy to just
be at home by myself or with my the
question is why did the dates go bad you
know what I mean cuz it's kind of okay
friends and then second this is the
second reason why I haven't met someone
yet tonight I'm meeting up with an old
coworker who I haven't seen in a long
time we were supposed to go out or
something and then I was like do you
want to just come over my house cuz like
it's cold outside I can make Appo and he
was like yeah yeah yeah like every time
I have the chance to go outside if
there's even like the slightest way to
make this be an inside thing I'm always
doing that like I'm always trying to
scam people into my home male friends
yeah okay cuz I don't want to be outside
but do you know what the problem with
that is the men are outside yeah it's
going to get more antisocial well and
she talks about why she's single and one
you know she didn't make it a priority
and two uh she kind of kind of puts it
on the guys you know what I mean like
the dates were bad well maybe you're a
bad dat or I don't know but let me know
what you guys think in the comments like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the Channel and I'll talk to you next
time